welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast on this week's episode i was
joined by danielle raynert who has
worked in the recruitment industry for
over 10 years she's someone that got
what she would call the recruitment bug
very early on what's really interesting
about danielle's journey is that over
the last five years at her company
called eames she's developed into a head
of performance and people role before
that she worked for a number of
companies as a billing manager as a
biller and then for the last four or
five years she's gone into a specific
lnd and talent acquisition role so we
spoke about everything on boarding how
to get more out of people how to develop
resilience and so much more enjoy the
episode danielle welcome to the podcast
titian thank you pleased to be here
really looking forward to this one
a lot of people i sit down with are
top performers
top builders recruiting entrepreneurs
but i think was really excited to
speak to you was this journey that
you've been on on being a recruiter and
now you're managing a team of 10
acquisition you're now managing a team
of learning development performance yeah
and obviously as we were talking before
i just really feel like where the market
is right now there probably has never
been more recruiters in the industry
that
need support new development and i think
a lot of companies struggle with that
so we're definitely going to touch on
who danny was in recruitment days okay
but we'll really focus on the sort of
last four on a bit years with eames yeah
um and all those things so where we
always like to start as a million pound
question which is i'd love to hear your
take on what you believe are the
characteristics and traits of a modern
day recruiter today that's really
successful that's a top performer okay
what are they what are those credits
that is the million dollar question
isn't it
i do get asked quite a lot um look i
think there's the usual stuff that
people will talk about and that's all
still really relevant so drive and
credibility in the market and all of
those things um i think when i look at
the high performers obviously at aims as
my most recent frame of reference i
suppose but even when i'm interviewing
people for eames as well at our
competitors the people who are the high
performers probably um the things i
would pick out it seems like an odd one
but this level of authenticity around
how they do what they do so they're not
hugely necessarily salesy you know when
i started in recruitment it was like
pick up the phone and sell to people and
tell them why you're the best recruiter
and why we're the best agency and what
your usps are and things like that
whereas i think actually people are
quite comfortable in their own skin
they're very normal they're quite humble
they are also very driven and
competitive and all of those things but
the way the way they go about it maybe
isn't quite as in your face that's so
interesting yeah that makes sense do you
think
that authenticity piece
do you think that it's more common to
find that in people that i guess have
gone on this journey to become more
comfortable in their skin or do you get
that odd sort of younger person that's
really i don't know i find i feel like
you have more chance of
being more authentic as
life goes on i feel like yeah quite
possibly when they kind of settle into
their own skin full stop i think it also
depends on the sort of business you work
for as well and how they encourage you
to work and develop and train you and
you know we're always talking about
trying to find that kind of authentic
sales style so if you're if you've got a
script shoved under your nose on your
first day and it's like right read that
on the phone very hard to make that
authentic
um but if people if agencies and it's
not just teams that do it other people
do as well kind of invest in working
with people on an individual basis to
help them develop their style then i
think it can happen quite quickly we
look at our associate consultants at the
moment and they all do the same job but
they all go about it quite differently
and they've all got their own kind of
style with it so as long as we keep
encouraging that as well as all the
basics and you know the other big things
for us things like accountability
consistency those are probably the two
other big ones so as long as those are
going on in the background as well
i think um yeah helping people to
develop that style and i think it also
helps retain people for longer in
recruitment generally as well when
you're cultivating them to be themselves
and absolutely yeah i love that so
always always interested in curious like
because so many people fall into the
industry
like who how would you describe danny
before recruitment
oh god danny before recruitment so um
i didn't really know what i want so i
always kind of knew i wanted to be good
at something okay i always wanted to be
successful but i was probably one of
those slightly mindless people like i'm
going to be really successful i'm going
to be really good at a job one day i had
no bloody idea what it was going to be
so i did quite a generic degree
you went uni i did go to uni um i
wouldn't necessarily advocate it for
everybody now because it was just a
massive waste of time and a waste of
money for me but it's not for everybody
obviously some people get a lot out of
it so i went to uni enjoyed my time in
manchester probably enjoyed it a bit too
much um didn't go too many lectures got
my degree and then it was a business
management degree from manchester united
it doesn't really set you up to be
anything specifically um so yeah it was
totally like what am i going to do and
my mum said to me well you're not moving
home so you find yourself a job
and it was 2009 so you know it was
obviously recession lehman's everything
so i applied for 98 jobs on monday
98 jobs on monster marketing recruitment
didn't even know what recruitment was no
idea and then i got a phone call
from a guy at premiere group and he said
you want to come for an interview and i
was like okay
and now here i am kind of 12 13 years
later still in recruitment i love that
so let's just talk a bit about those
because so you've been at eames for
nearly five years right yeah nearly five
yeah and then before prior to that it
was all
you you was a recruiter you progressed
and these types of things so yeah
i guess what what were a lot of people
listen to this that are sort of probably
early on in their recruitment career or
really in the trenches right now what
were what was your most difficult year
looking back do you think in your
recruitment career is it the first year
of which a lot of people say did you get
did you sort of um
pick up what you needed to do quite
quickly i don't know how like how are
the early years the the early years i've
got to say the earlier the first year in
recruitment for me was brilliant i
absolutely loved it um so i learned a
lot of premiere like they they trained
me and it was very fast-paced and i
absolutely got bitten by the recruitment
bug shall we say um my hardest year was
probably um in my next business when i
was predominantly a contract recruiter i
fell into that trap of having one big
client
that was like 80 of my nfi or billings
you know on a quarterly and annual basis
and then overnight they had a an
external consultancy come in and say you
need to get rid of all your contractors
and turn it all to perm
so yeah that was that was difficult yeah
that was difficult yeah trying to pick
yourself up from that and kind of
refocus and things um and you know it
happens it does so you just gotta be a
bit resilient and stick with it really
and then have you always done a mixture
of like contract amphem or pretty much
yeah i've always been in quite a
fortunate position i mean when i was at
um premiere i was i was all perm yeah um
but i managed to swing a few things
contracts you know i'd be like yeah i'll
do that
oh it definitely started as a perm job
um and and then when i was in my other
roles yeah it was it was predominantly
your desk what would you what would you
say are the things that you absolutely
have to know and get really good at as a
contract recruiter compared to
a perm recruiter for it for instance
that's a really interesting question
because people are people we talk about
that aim sometimes now and how we train
and develop people differently and
things like that i try not to separate
them out too much if i'm completely
honest i think
there you can fall into the trap of
thinking that contract recruiters have
to work with real pace and urgency and
that side of things and on perm you can
maybe be a bit slow i always say that
people like yeah i bring the contract
agency to perm recruitment and it's sort
of like yeah
i think taking the same mindset i think
with um with perm obviously with
contracts i think it's this element of
tracking your contractors and constantly
keeping on top of them so if you make a
contract placement and you've placed a
contractor with a client and then you
don't speak to them for the six-month
contract you have absolutely missed a
trick there because you need to be well
on top of your contract finishers and
your run rate and everything and making
sure you're keeping these guys on your
books as much as possible so i think the
level of proactivity of replacing your
candidates as a contract recruiter is
absolutely paramount whereas on perm
once you've placed somebody you still
need to keep in touch with them but for
different reasons it's a different kind
of relationship yeah do you have a good
memory i always feel like contract
recruiters are like yeah i've got like
that's i'm sure you've heard i do yeah i
sometimes think i don't have a good
memory and then like someone like my
husband would be like you've pulled me
up on something i did like six years ago
how do you still remember that i'm sure
there was an argument we had six years
ago so i think i probably did i'm sure
you picked up on that people like yeah
like i just i remember like someone was
telling me about some of them like yeah
i remember i placed that person that uh
yeah yeah i find that so interesting
yeah you do have to have a good memory
so when when did when did like where did
you get to in your career then to then
be open or consider
like a type of role or what the
opportunity might look like at iam's
like where did you end up in your career
to then consider going down the path
that you did go down yeah so i think
when i was a recruiter i mean anyone
could see from my linkedin i was what i
would look at as a slightly jumpy
profile so i was never out anywhere for
a really long time um
and i think it's because i was still
trying to work out what i wanted to do
in recruitment if that makes sense yeah
and then i joined aspire and the role
was very much uh
i came in to do one thing and i think
the role evolved quite quickly and i
ended up doing something quite different
which was heavily involved with hiring a
different type of skill set from the
market for them and then training those
individuals and supporting them with
their development so having quite
organically to get into that role yeah
and then i just loved that part of the
role um so what do you love about it
i loved seeing people come in and get
really um
bitten by that recruitment bug and as i
mean i use that phrase all the time
which is really irritating but do you
know what i mean by that yeah so kind of
be really enthusiastic about recruitment
and see how it could be a long-term
career as well because you do have
people come in that admittedly it's
maybe a bit of a separate stepping stone
they don't know what else to do
and taking somebody's confidence and
skill set and working with them to take
it from one level to the next level and
they see the financial rewards from that
oh god absolutely yeah definitely better
than
your biggest deal or best month or um
you know what it's different i think
different things get you out of bed in
the morning as you get older as well so
i think you know first commission checks
and stuff like that amazing still
remember first deal and all that kind of
stuff and how exciting it is but i think
you know to be able to have that
influence on others and to be able to
make it happen for other people
i started getting a kick out of that
quite early on in my career when i
started managing people so it kind of
naturally became you know the role i
ended up in was around
people so i guess to to round that off
then always curious like what what do
you think a like you said you wasn't
sure what you wanted to do but you
didn't you sort of had expectations of
yourself you want to be successful what
what has a career in the recruitment
industry given you that maybe you you
least expected
um
i think it well it's given me my husband
and my best friends
my whole life revolves around working in
recruitment so if i haven't worked in
recruitment i'd be pretty lonely at this
point
well i like to think i probably would
have found them somewhere else but yeah
i mean i've made some great friends
great network um i've also been able to
really advise other people in my life so
family and other friends that obviously
i do have a few outside of recruitment
um on big those big life-changing
moments like looking for a new role
struggling at work feeling demotivated
not feeling supported how to have
conversations around salaries and pay
rises you know if i hadn't worked in
recruitment and advised people on that
as part of my job i wouldn't have been
able to do that it's probably useful
isn't it yeah right when i still get
people messaging me going my mom's like
my second cousin's uncle's aunt wants a
new cv
i haven't looked at cvs for a really
long time yeah but
yeah it's yeah my girlfriend reese had
been hiring for her team and like yeah
i'll just catch myself just it's just
information that you always keep yeah
and it is really useful and like when
you it is interesting because like if
you never
have gotten in that environment
you realize that oh wow yeah all of that
stuff that i learned is really useful
within like really in potential
important moments in your career yeah so
interesting so let's sort of unpack this
journey then with him so like when you
because i know you were saying upstairs
like you joined on a six-month contract
and then you've now been there for
nearly five years yeah so have you
always been in the mixture of like
talent acquisition and learning
development or has that evolved over
time or like how did it how did it start
so it has evolved so why join deems on a
sit yes you're right six month contract
to basically be like a sales trainer
okay and for me it was going to be a
kind of one of multiple clients so
things that i was going to do so i set
up my limited company set up a bank
account you know business bank account
kind of what is the company called um
recruitment trainers limited so super
exciting really creative really thinking
outside the box
i think i still own the website domain
if everyone wants to buy it
pretty valuable yeah um so joined on the
six-month contract only it was only
going to be sales training and it was
only going to be for the six months
because that's all that was going to be
required and then eames
um through that journey matthew eames
and the board decided to make a big
investment in
learning and development and training
and
driving performance across the business
and sort of building an l d function out
so they would started looking for a
permanent head of people and performance
and they went to market which is the
right thing to do and i put my hat in
the ring and interviewed for it as well
um and and got the job and at that point
i took over the the talent acquisition
side of things as well because what it
would probably be helpful like so when
do you remember what the business looked
like at that period like how many people
were there like roughly good question so
i think that'll be in i think that'll
give some really good context of like i
know you have big goals yeah the next
financial year and stuff but rough idea
of what the business looked like when
you was at that period it was it was
definitely smaller than it is now it
wasn't astronomically smaller but if in
terms of head count it was smaller in
terms of um look at other factors like
um nfi or billings per head on a monthly
and quarterly basis was lower he was
definitely different um
and just in terms of the the kind of the
the the access to training and
development stuff like it was there
there was someone doing some but there's
only so much one person can do so yeah
it was it was quite different so how
many and then what would be helpful now
is that so how many people do you have
in your people and performance team
cause you're telling me upstairs so it'd
be good to sort of paint a picture of
what that looks like today absolutely so
um the team to my team today there's
seven of us in the uk um and then there
are people in our um um hong kong and
singapore offices as well so just made a
new hire who's due to start on as an l d
manager in our singapore office who will
cover the asia region um and then
someone that supports us with talent
acquisition out there for the asia
region as well so and in the uk there's
um yes seven of us seven of you cool so
let's just i really want to dig into
this like performance piece basically
so i think what would be really
interesting to hear your take on is like
what are the principles and fundamentals
to get to getting onboarding right
more particularly around how can i take
danny who knows absolutely nothing about
recruitment that has the the
authenticity how the curiosity has has
the right things yeah like as a as a
culture as a business like what are some
of the principles and fundamentals that
you've probably really sort of worked
hard on getting right now yeah that can
really help that person go from like
zero to being competent as quickly as
possible or get into that first
milestone of dinner deal more quickly
like what are the principles and getting
that right yeah cool so if i break that
down the initial part would be that
onboarding piece
so it's something that we spent a lot of
time looking at reviewing doing feedback
surveys on tweaking getting right i
think it all starts with making sure
that the hiring process and that talent
acquisition piece is intrinsically
linked to the onboarding and the l d
piece so in my case that's easy because
i manage both of those functions um but
it means that actually we are setting
clear expectations and agreeing
speaking to people like joining them
when we're interviewing them so it
starts before someone's even joining the
business so i think you got to get that
bit right first and make sure that
you're giving a really honest
transparent account of
this is eems this is what we're great at
these are the challenges if you were to
join this is the role
this is how that manager operates this
is how we use things like kpis if you
were to join the business we use
something called what good looks like
which sets out very clear billing
expectations for everybody at every
level in the business so we can provide
that to people before they've even
started and say look are you up for this
because this this will be the end i'm
glad you brought it out because we can
go into
what you've learned and spend a lot of
time on but if you're not bringing the
right people in that environment from
the first place and you're setting
yourself up to fail or it's just going
to be way more difficult i'm glad you
made that point okay so let's say we've
got the right person the right person
what like what what do we have to get
right or like what are the fundamentals
i think making sure you put enough time
and planning into the onboarding and
induction and what we have is two sort
of very different approaches to
onboarding depending on the profile of
individual we bring in okay so we have
the ac pod an academy whatever you want
to call it we call it the ac pod so
there is a structured process for
onboarding an induction for those guys
um the way that we train them develop
them measure and set expectations
measure performance how long is that
period the ac pod lasts between four to
six months oh wow really yeah okay so
the initial pod is very intense for the
first sort of two
but then you're in ac pod in various
different phases right up until the
point you get promoted to a consultant
so for some people that could be sort of
actually more like five months some
people it could be eight or nine it's
online yeah and like so like what goes
on in that period i'm just really
interested in like what goes on in that
period yeah so the ac pod is structured
around our core training modules okay so
we break that down into working with
candidates job management and business
development broadly
um and in the first two weeks we we hire
in sort of and we training three week
periods so the first two weeks really
full-on training yeah every hour is
scheduled out um which sounds really
intense but you're never sort of
squirreled away in a training room for
hours and hours on end mix it up
different environments we go to
different we works different offices
different people involved in
facilitating and delivering training so
i could be doing some my l d team the
managers and directors get really
involved in delivering training first
hand as well um so you're in doing
learning theory you're doing uh having
opportunities to put it into practice
doing things like role plays which are a
lot of fun you know i get them to put me
through my paces as well to see if i've
still got it um and then you get the
opportunity to obviously put it into
practice on desk you hear those stories
don't you and i remember my first couple
of weeks i was in a much smaller
business but i was on the phones on the
first day so i was just curious yeah
like how long is it until like they go
into like the real world they're
speaking to candidates like so on desk
day three day three day three so what
we're trying to find is a balance and
this is a really i was actually
interviewing someone last night and
talking to her about it it's really hard
balance to get sometimes between
wanting to make sure that juniors have
enough confidence credibility they know
enough to have a valuable conversation
with a candidate not waste a candidate's
time be able to represent our brand
effectively yeah um but at the same time
you don't want to keep them off the
phone so long that it kind of builds up
into this massive thing and it's like oh
[ __ ] we're going to go on the phones
next week it's like guys it's just a
phone call we've done a role play a
hundred times um so
yeah we just need to find that balance
and from looking at the data which we
try and do as much as possible we know
that people perform better by the end of
month one if they're on the phone by day
three that's interesting yeah so why do
you think that is then because i think
because that is the right thing
yeah i think it's important and with the
training again we changed it up because
i'm proud of where we are now but it's
definitely been a journey to get to
where it is initially we were giving
them too much information and asking
them to do too much on that first call
and now we've scaled it back and it's
like actually in day three you're doing
more what we would call candidate regen
calls so people who are on our database
we've maybe lost contact with for a
while and they're getting in touch and
saying you know i'm like to find out if
you're open to a new opportunity at the
moment got your details on our system
we're not spoken for a while you know
having that level of conversation
they're not pitching them a job yeah
making the mistakes less higher yeah
exactly and then it's just used to
picking up the phone speaking to
candidates getting things like you know
i'm not i'm not able to speak right now
or you know why are you calling me take
my details off your system you know or
yes great really keen so it's just
putting them through those different
real life scenarios and not leaving it
too long but not expecting them to do
too much on that day three because they
still don't know very well that's a
that's a really interesting insight to
be fair so off so after those two weeks
that are really intense
like
is it then just a real blended approach
of like learning in their teams or are
they still in the pot like how does it
work so on in the first two weeks they
actually physically sit on a podcast
together as well yeah
obviously really intentional that you do
yes so they all sit together they're all
going through the same experiences
they're all going through the highs and
lows or getting on the phone for the
first time um someone is always managing
that pod so it would be myself my one of
my l d team or one of the managers of
those uh those acs that have joined so
someone is always taking responsibility
for them on that pod for listening in on
calls desk coaching making sure they get
into training on time all that kind of
stuff so that's the first two weeks week
three is kind of a bedding in week so
that's the week where we don't teach
them any new theory it's all about
putting it into practice and that's when
they're out sitting amongst the sales
teams i mean this pod in the first week
is on the sales floor so they're not
like away in a room somewhere never like
so they're all on the same journey which
is really hard
exactly and they're building that those
relationships and that cohort as well
um and we see them kind of go through
that cohort for the whole time that
they're at eames you know what i mean
i would say to people if you join a pod
of nine you've got eight new best
friends on day one that's great i love
that hey everyone a real quick one from
me this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sauce breaker because you
listened to this podcast you were able
to get your hands on exclusive savings
on both of these award-winning products
if you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with sourcebreaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products
so something really specific here but
i'm sure you've like i feel like you've
sort of dealt with it by
sort of really talking to them about the
fundamentals and getting that in early
but i speak to a lot of companies where
one of their biggest challenges is
you have people in
different teams managed by different
people
who
work different ways yeah
have you navigated that because i was
just thinking like they're going to
their managers then what if they're
going yeah no no no we don't do it like
we don't do it like that don't listen to
that yeah
that's such a good question and it's
something that makes me smile because
it's happened to me in various different
ways so first and foremost i have to be
really careful that i don't constantly
default to training people to be a
contract tech recruiter because that's
what i want
and when i first joined eames they
talked to me about the actuarial market
which is one of our biggest divisions i
was like
that's completely different
i don't even know what it is i don't
know how to spell it so um and they work
completely differently it's incredibly
candidate driven market you're playing
that kind of long game with candidate
relationships really job rich so
completely different to any market i'd
worked in so the immediate thing was i
needed to learn and i needed to adapt my
style to be able to train people for all
the different teams that eames
when we bring them into the pod what
we're trying to do is very consciously
explain to people we are training you on
the nuts and bolts of recruitment
um when it comes to sales recruitment
process bd all of those key things and
then we're always trying to bring
relevant examples from all the teams
across eames but we always caveat it
with there are particular things that
your manager will want to add in the
kind of nuances of that particular
market so things like cv formatting and
things like that in actuarial versus
contract tech looks very different in
terms of the expectations
market mapping candidate mapping
candidate head hunting and things like
that in actuarial they're doing it all
day every day it's a huge part of what
they do other areas a bit more job board
driven or get more responses to adverts
and things so yeah we've had to work
with the managers so that they're really
linked in at all times with what we're
training people on if l d and the
managers and directors that manage those
acs aren't joined up then there's going
to be lots of mixed messages so the more
joined up we are and the better the
follow-up and the feedback and agreeing
what the application on desk and things
looks like after training the better
that is and the better the experience is
for the junior yes if you're in that if
you if you find yourself in a difficult
moment right now and you're listening
it's like right what what are you doing
to build those manager relationships
like you have to get on the same page or
you at least have to make sure you're
communicating together and there's some
yeah agreeables and you yeah okay that's
really interesting because yeah i've
spoke to
because because the daily conversations
i have now are around 11 development the
people obviously and as you all know
i'm sure you've picked up on it but most
people like in the role that you're in
it is typically a team of one or it is a
team of like maybe two people so it can
be really difficult but that's a
challenge that i've heard quite a few
times yeah and it doesn't happen
overnight either building credibility
and relationships with the managers and
directors was a big
journey for me you know and it is it's
you know there's somebody coming in
that's worked in a different market that
isn't in their team that's telling you
know advising their new starters this is
how you do it it's how you do a bd call
um and it so it's not going to happen
overnight i don't think there's a silver
bullet but it is about being respectful
you know asking questions i sit with all
the different teams a lot so i could get
a first-hand insight into
how they operate the language they use
you know the differences between the
teams and then i can bring that into the
training and that's exactly what my l d
team do we're out there sitting amongst
the teams yeah i think what i really
take from that is yeah you've got to
really integrate and be proactive and
get involved like you said if it's not
okay so another specific thing
because i hear it a lot is people who
are early on in their career a real
common challenge and i would say i
definitely had periods of this but a
really common challenge that i hear that
sort of prevents people maybe maximizing
their potential more quickly is just
this idea or feeling of they're not good
enough to be speaking to ex people that
they're now speaking to so for example
i did like um a specific sort of early
on in recruitment series on this podcast
and one of the things that i definitely
took from that which is really
interesting was had people like yourself
that were in uni were in a library
studying two weeks ago now they're in at
ease and they're speaking to actuary
people they're speaking insurance
professionals are going [ __ ] out like
what value can i bring to this person
all the
how do you how do you and there'll be a
lot of people listening that are on that
journey at the moment yeah
how do you how do you help people
overcome that yeah roadblock or hurdle
yeah so there we do some specific
training around becoming a subject
matter expert okay okay and i think it's
it's especially prevalent that mindset
and that worry when you work for a
business like eames which is all about
you know brand and um being a specialist
in your market and why be you know
that's the value we add to our
candidates your niche you're focusing
only incredibly niche you know you're
within a niche within a niche within a
niche because that's how we believe we
can add value and we see people being
very successful doing it so it can be
really overwhelming for people but i'll
break it down and explain to people that
you are first and foremost a recruiter
so don't get away from that and i think
that sometimes it means we used to a
little bit and it was like you know
you're not an actuary and you're not
expected to be and you're not expected
to be so the training is very
interactive and i will and i do it the
same with bd as well when people are
worried about ringing clients i say to
them you know why do candidates use
recruitment agencies recruitment agents
what do we do what value do we add to
them what service do we provide
so it's not about being cocky or
arrogant but it's just about helping
juniors solidify in their mind the value
they can add without all the subject
matter expertise without knowing the
inside outs of being an actuary and one
what we're basically always getting to
is they are the gatekeepers to access to
the experts if you like to the eems
senior principal consultants who have
worked in the market for years and have
all that credibility the acs are out
there speaking to candidates and
essentially they're not saying i'm an
expert i know all the answers i know all
the answers we never encourage and i
really i feel strongly about it ac is to
pretend they know more than they do
because you're setting them up to fail
so there is a very credible way to get
on the phone on day three
know very very very little about your
market and still provide a service to
candidates so it's about unlocking that
with the acs right i call maybe that's
what we call the association
yeah
in days one and two so they can really
understand what value they can add and
if they are ever challenged how they
handle that and how they handle that and
bring their manager into it and have a
valuable conversation with a candidate
so if people are struggling with that
right now i think that's a really good
exercise isn't it because you can you
can get lost and go down the path of
like thinking that you have to
be as uh
like competent as a tech people that
you're speaking to or the insurance
people but actually take a step back and
think about where can you add the most
value as a recruiter as you said if it's
the gatekeeper to the experienced people
in in your business or it could be well
i speak to uh hundreds of people like
i'm gonna be able to speak to way more
people like you in the day so there's
some um insight and information that i
could share so yeah that's probably a
good thing to think about if you're
struggling with that right and just ask
questions just ask candidates questions
people love talking typically about
their career their job i'm sitting there
doing it with you today loving it so um
you know people like talking about
themselves so be inquisitive that's what
i'd say to candidates and don't worry
about if you get asked a question
don't blag it i used to try and do that
when i started in recruitment and you
tie yourself up in knots just say i
don't know the answer but can i come
back to you by the end of the day and
let you know
absolutely 100 it ties back to that okay
so on this performance piece then
beyonce so this is what i've learned as
well over the last light year or so so
what i typically find and i don't know
how you feel about this but
most the development investment or time
goes into that early period
and then what i found some of the most
underinvested people in recruitment
companies are the people that have been
doing it for a couple of years yeah the
top performers yeah they oftentimes get
forgotten about yeah so danny's owning
loads of money like she i'm sure she's
fine
so
like talk to me about a bit about that
how do you then think about performance
development upskilling giving people
consistent learning opportunities beyond
the the pods and beyond the early period
how do you view that so i think it's
about how making sure you've got a good
structure around your performance
management framework if you like so
everybody in the business has weekly
one-to-ones with their manager always
and sometimes that can be a quick
check-in and sometimes those are a bit
longer um so understanding things on a
regular basis and where somebody's at
and having those check-ins for sort of
week-to-week performance and things um
then you're looking at your professional
development plan meetings your personal
pdps essentially which are quarterly so
that's the opportunity to be doing those
deep dives and we're not all about
form-filling and stuff like that aims
but we really do get people to think
before those meetings what do you want
to be achieving in the next three months
what have your block has been okay
you've i referenced what could look like
what good looks like earlier yes you're
performing an excellent but how do we
take it to the next level and what do
you want
to achieve what do you want to achieve
why do you want to achieve it
you know what does that look like for
you in terms of your life in work
outside of work you know what's the
impact of that on you
and how do we help support you get there
so for some people it's earning more
money for some people it's taking on a
broader role in the business i've got
some senior principal consultants at the
moment who
couldn't be performing any higher you
know they're performing exceptionally at
eames and they are really keen to get
involved with l d so their managers are
like oh my god they're not moving into
an l d role it's like no no but how can
we support them to put a plan in place
to get them involved in training juniors
and mentoring and those things but it
all starts with those regular
conversations with those high performers
and the pdps are caught in a great
vehicle to do that to understand what do
they want to be achieving how can you
help them and how can we gather
information otherwise you've got no
chance of you yeah and it's got to come
from them they've got to own it they've
got to take accountability for it and
then we as a business support them to
make that come true and make that happen
yeah really interesting so i get another
be good to get your thoughts on this as
well is a really interesting question i
got so i sort of i was at a networking
event the other week in manchester and i
sort of shared that
and because of what we're sort of doing
with the learning platform where it's
like all top performers and i'm speaking
to these people a lot of the times and i
just find it so interesting that they
just feel really under-invested then
yeah
and the the question i got was it's
really interesting that you shared that
adhesion but how do i
manage or deal with someone that may
feel under-invested in but feels like
they know it all
yeah but i'm sure you've sort of had
those sort of people things to deal with
so maybe it seems like you've got the
intentional space which helps on those
pdps
but like i guess you might be aware of
something that goes you know what there
might be a bit of a flight risk or a bit
of a risk
but they i it's it's hard to get it out
of them that they may to for them to
share that they maybe want some support
or extra investment have you ever had it
like i don't know if you've got any
insights on that i do not i do broadly
know what you mean i think i think it's
about looking at
i think it's about taking as a manager
or as an ahead of people and performance
you know l d whatever you want to call
me it's about taking the ego out of it
and going am i the best person to engage
with this individual on that interesting
is there somebody else in the business
that actually we could bring in at this
point to do not necessarily formal
mentoring but that could add value to
this person that isn't their direct line
manager isn't in md
um and we um we played that you know
played that card we've done that quite a
few times we've got you know mark in our
contract and tech team who's a director
and he i think you know mark and he's
all about business development so it
doesn't matter who you are in the
business or which team you sit in
someone's struggling with bd they need
some inspiration they need to talk to
someone that's going to like that bd
fire i can do it from an l d perspective
but i know the right times when it's top
performance to draft marking and there's
no ego involved in that it's what's
going to get the best out of this person
and what's going to add value to them
yeah really interesting so a couple more
points that i will really want to make
sure that we go over before we finish so
retention mm-hmm talk to me about that
what's been your journey with that what
are some some of the i think
this is a lot of companies right now
will be worried about
losing their best people yeah
like how how how do you feel like
because i feel like when i look at ems
you do have a lot of long-standing
people there including including
yourself so what are some of the things
that you think
really impact retention and keeps people
happy keeps people yeah fulfilled in a
recruitment environment how do you feel
about retention and what helps it a big
question isn't it
there's no
yeah what are the things you think about
a lot that you feel really move the
needle on that absolutely so if i think
about myself and when i look at our
retention our journey that we've been on
i think that having um i think a level
of fairness around everything that we do
i talk about fairness a lot so things
like a crystal clear and fair and
transparent career path for people so
you can join as an associate consultant
and know everything you need to do in
order to become a principal consultant
in the business irrespective of which
team you're in which manager you report
into it kind of takes that subjectivity
out of it if you like so there's no
favoritism there's no moving goal posts
which i think really frustrates people
really really frustr i hear about it in
interviews sometimes i just think why
would a business do that why why have
you chosen to make that call and you
look people make decisions for all
various reasons but i think not moving
the goal post being fair
um
and catching things early you know
nobody should be coming to you and
saying you know i'm due a pay rise and i
always do it because i hit that target
and it hasn't happened or nobody should
be coming into a pdp meeting or a
one-to-one and going and thinking that
they've hit their targets and they're
gonna get promoted or whatever it might
be and it doesn't happen yeah fairness
and clarity fairness and clarity
absolutely and how you communicate with
your business you know you can't as a
business the business matthew eames the
board etc they can't communicate
everything that's going on all the time
with everybody the information overload
some of it's confidential it wouldn't be
appropriate but where possible thinking
about how and what you communicate and
when you do it and communicating things
sooner rather than later with people
gives them a sense of trust with the
business as well i think
and also giving them a voice for
feedback and things and not assuming
that because we're senior or we sit on
the smt that we've got all the answers
yeah i really like that how how do you
keep your biggest achievers motivated
pay them very well
because i think that's an interesting
one as well
i've had a few people on here share that
like when they
when they achieved that top bill of
status it's like
they then ended up having like their
worst year or like their most difficult
year okay yeah i just find that really
interesting and you hear a lot don't you
when people like i listen to a podcast
where that whole sort of gold medal
syndrome where you get the gold medal
and then you're just absolutely
depressed because you've got nothing
else to like work or whatever but i
think it impacts retention as well
because it does people like matt has
always always been thinking is my top
performer going to go and start their
own business tomorrow yeah that's always
something that could happen okay yeah so
i was just curious along with that
retention piece you've got a lot of
people that have been there for a while
probably doing well like how do you how
do you it seems like you mentioned the
lnd thing earlier that they're getting
involved but how do you
how do you view getting them um
keeping them motivated yeah so i think
it's part of it not necessarily day to
day but i think part of it is rooted in
the fact that
we have very strong career path for
people who don't want to manage as much
as people who do so i think part of it
for big billers can be
especially the reason behind having
their worst year is because they've got
to becoming a really good biller and
then the business kind of pushes them
down that management route as an
organization every recruitment company
wants great managers that you can build
people build teams underneath and
that would help our growth plans
brilliantly if all of our top performers
said you know i want to build as much as
i am today and i want to manage a team
of four ac's that would be a dream but
that's not necessarily the right thing
for those individuals so i think it's
creating a career path that aims for
people that is suited to the job that
they do the skills they have their
motivations and their career aspirations
so you can become a director of sales
like marcus for example we've got ads of
sales and then we also have the
partnership scheme at eames as well
where you become a partner in the
business and you're more involved
strategically and working with the board
and things like that so rather than just
yeah like just having the management
leadership route yeah rather than just
you know rather than that kind of
fighting building of the if you've got
the biggest team and you've got loads of
direct reports then you've got a bigger
seat at the table um and that's
absolutely not the case we have people
that don't manage anyone who are ad
sales and partners in the business who
have a huge amount of influence over
day-to-day running of the organization
input feedback et cetera and they add a
huge amount of value beyond just their
billings and i think that's really yeah
that's right that's right and then it
kind of back then to the fairness
clarity again that absolutely they know
that that's the route they can go down
yes
again i know i'm just getting really
specific here but that's all right and
then and then the other the other thing
that i find really interesting is people
listen to this would love their people
to be more consistent
how do you how how how have you how do
you think about unlocking consistency in
people yeah consistently
i can give a really specific answer
there's more to it than this yeah but
for me a lot of it comes down to data
data so how we use data at eames so we
don't use data to beat people with with
like a stick or anything but i think
looking at people's things like
dashboards in our crm system going
through that on a kind of a weekly basis
in one to ones the pdps you start to see
trends in data so you start to you know
really simply be able to say to someone
right you've had an absolutely cracking
month this month let's have a look at
the two months leading up to that and
what were the outputs what the
activities what were your activities
what were you doing
along with what was your mindset what
did you know was there anything else
going on you know what kept you
particularly motivated the why behind
why that activity was higher and then if
someone has a [ __ ] quarter the next
quarter guess what let's have a look at
the data again oh look let's compare the
two you send a third of the number of
cvs you booked half the number of client
meetings so it's not about bringing it
back to kpis all the time but data is a
brilliant tool to use to be able to use
fact along with the context of the
person and the individual and and having
a conversation around it that's really
good how and then what because some
smaller companies may think they they
may not have the the finance the
financials to invest in the best tools
and data like what what what tools have
you what tools you use to get to really
be able to clearly see those data points
yeah i mean we purely use salesforce
lightning crm so oh really we've had it
customized we haven't we don't use any
other plug-ins and stuff like that at
the moment i know there's lots out there
like cube19s and things like that um not
here to sell anything
but people are interested yeah we don't
use anything else at the moment we just
use the crm religiously we certainly
didn't four years ago that is definitely
a journey we've been on but that's a
whole other podcast um but the you know
making sure that the mentality is if
it's not on the system it didn't happen
but i think it tracks it back to making
sure people understand the reason why
there's a certain level of activity that
needs to happen in order for them to be
successful yeah um so we log stuff on
the on the crm system so you can do that
on any crm
and we use sort of dashboard reporting
functionality and stuff which is pretty
good on salesforce i got to it's it's
excellent
and really insightful and it's very you
know color coded and all stuff like that
so it's quite visual for people as well
but i think the most important thing is
whatever approach you take to using data
be consistent with it i think if a
manager's going into a one-to-one one
week because someone's not billing and
they've had a [ __ ] week or their
attitude's dropped off a cliff and they
go
look at this data why you sent look at
this and they go what the [ __ ] that
i've never seen that before
then that doesn't work and that's
oftentimes when the data comes out isn't
it yeah it's like oh absolutely but the
data needs to come out when someone's
performing really well as well to go and
they can see the link they can yeah
absolutely and you can look at where you
can still make those marginal gains
which is what we're looking for with top
performers
so a couple final things then had a this
is more specific to like you as an lnd
um professional and going on a journey
okay so i speak to someone yesterday
that made me think about this where
obviously he was he was just telling me
how he doesn't want to be another one of
those recruitment trainers that just
goes in the room and tells people to do
it the way that he did it and that's why
i should listen
so he was really he was he was he was
one asking me if i knew anyone that he
could connect with and these types of
things but also like what sort of things
should i look at to him i want to i want
to be able to bring
the um the was it the sort of l d
insights and the understanding and
education of an l d professional to
recruitment training rather than just
being that person that i was a
300k tech recruiter
i mean so also i can see that you've
invested in the cipd and you've invested
in yourself so get some more specific
question on like why did you do that
have you found that help you because i
had that question yesterday i think
that's interesting i'm sure you can
relate to that you probably was aware
that you didn't want to be
yeah you should listen to me because i
was a good recruiter
absolutely so i think the storytelling
element of training can be really
powerful still so but it's not about you
know if i look at that example it's not
by going you should do this because i
build 400k seven years ago it's also
about going through your war stories and
where you [ __ ] up and got it wrong and
where you had the terrible months and
you know being empathetic and being able
to kind of share that journey a bit and
anyone that's ever been trained by me
knows that i'll share all my war stories
and everything as well as the top tips
as well but you know the world moves on
so i think it is about remaining current
so it's making sure that you know when i
did my cipd
i invested in that because i wanted i
had a bit of imposter syndrome in all
honesty i moved into this role head of
people and performance i was like [ __ ]
this is and that's what this guy
probably found yeah i was like this
isn't what i was expecting so in part i
did it because i thought it would give
me a bit of credibility but at the same
time as well i hadn't been in a
structured learning environment myself
since uni so i wanted to experience a
bit of that learning something new being
out of your depth you know taking on
information applying it you know all of
that learning again because that's what
i was asking other people to do and i
was in a room doing but i hadn't done it
for ages myself so i wanted to go
through that experience again um
can i hand on heart say that i use
everything that i got taught in my cipd
no but things around key messaging like
data and how people you know need to be
more socially aware now online and
brought that personal brand and
supporting people develop that that just
wasn't a thing when i was a recruiter so
there were one or two key things i
really got from it
but i think yeah thinking of new ways
that i can add value to people things
like doing my nlp and things like that
um it just brings a different dynamic to
the training content that we're
delivering yeah really interesting so as
you come to the end here then i guess
what i'd love to just close on is for
anyone listen to this that doesn't have
the the privilege of having someone like
you in their business or
it's always a privilege yeah but like
yeah i guess
yeah a lot of people don't have someone
like you a team in that right so i guess
the sort of question is and to get your
sort of final thoughts on is like if i'm
listening to this and there's a number
of people in my business that i know i
should probably be supporting more and
provide more development opportunities
for like what would be your advice for
those people um
like things that they could do or the
how they should be thinking about it uh
that doesn't necessarily mean like oh it
makes them feel like i have to have an l
d team and these types of things like if
i'm listening to this and yeah like what
would your advice be to those people
that could help get more out of those
people help support those people yeah i
think the the first thing i would do it
sounds a bit of an odd thing to suggest
but the first thing i'll say is people
naturally who work in l d love talking
about l d and very often other people in
the business don't love talking about it
as much as we do so we don't get to
natter about it very much i would reach
out to people even if they are your
competitors people in my sort of role
and ask what do you guys do what do you
have in place i'd be very surprised if
they get shut down too often because
people approach me all the time so
sharing those ideas and building a
network within that kind of l d space i
think making sure you do have that
structured performance framework is so
important it does take time
yeah the onboarding and making sure
there's the onboarding process and make
sure that's mapped out and it's
consistent for everybody that joins um
making sure there are the one-to-ones
the pdps you know if people are
underperforming then the desk reviews to
help them get back on track that it's
clear it's consistent it's fair and
there is some form of process in place
and knowing who can be in your business
to support you as a business owner if
we're talking about kind of smaller
businesses in driving those things
forward and making sure people are
educated about the support they get from
your business um so i think when
businesses are smaller they maybe assume
i don't need all that process i don't
need that structure we're not 150 200
people we'll wait to that point so you
know if we get there we'll worry about
that stuff
and it's not assuming that because you
catch up with people on the desk every
day and you know what jobs they got on
and you know what the pipeline looks
like that they don't need that time
one-on-one in a room to talk about their
development and their performance and
how important that is to employees um so
yeah i hear that a lot when i speak to
people sometimes outside of our business
and they go oh well you know i know
what's going on because we speak all the
time so we don't really need that
structure you do they need to know that
they've got that time with you that that
and just sometimes that time
intentional perspective intentional
space to talk about it's a great way of
putting it yeah and it's that time with
you as i know as their manager yeah
that's just as important as going on a
training program or sitting in a
coaching session with a me or one of my
team or a workshop that we run at eames
or something that time that space that
coaching that you can do one-on-one with
someone even if you're a small business
and making sure it's regular and doesn't
just happen when the ship hits the fan
and they're underperforming love it dan
it's been a pleasure thank you thank you
so much thank you so much for listening
to the episode i hope you enjoyed it and
got value from the conversation if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode
[Music]